تبدو
متعبًا ، حان وقت الليل ، فلنذهب
لاختيار الكتب
أنا كلوي وهذا زوجي
بريان ولدينا صبيان صغيران ، ليو ولوك
ليو في الرابعة من العمر ، لوك في الثانية
ولا ينامون طوال الليل إذا
فعلوا ذلك.  نادرًا ما ينامون طوال
الليل يستيقظون مبكرًا حقًا
، وكلاهما
يستيقظان بحلول الساعة الخامسة والنصف والنصف صباحًا ، أشعر بصراحة أن لديهم شعورًا
بالضيق وأريد التسكع معي في
الصباح ،
هل تريد أن ترى أبي لدي مثل هذا
المجزأ  جدول النوم في
الصباح أشعر أحيانًا أنه
معلق تمامًا لأنني متعب جدًا ،
ثم يجعلني مضطربًا ومن ثم يمكن أن
يسبب مشاكل في زواج
والدي أكثر متعة ، لقد حاولت إدخال
آلات الصوت الميلاتونين تعتيم
الستائر لكننا ذاهبون  لمحاولة الحصول على
بعض المساعدة من طبيب النوم
وأعتقد أننا نحتاج حقًا إلى المساعدة بشكل صحيح ،
هل يبدو هذا طبيعيًا ،
إنها مشكلة شائعة جدًا
ولكن ليس من الطبيعي أن يكون لدى الدكتور مارك
وايزبلوث خبرة تزيد عن 30 عامًا في
طب الأطفال
كتب شائعة عن اضطرابات النوم وهو
جد يبلغ من العمر 10 سنوات. تحدثنا لمدة ساعة
واستبعدنا المشكلات الصحية الرئيسية ثم
دخلنا في أسلوب قواعد النوم ،
لذلك تكون قواعد النوم
هذه وعندما يتم إطفاء الأنوار
نبقى في السرير ونحاول  للنوم حتى
تنطفئ بعض الإشارات في الصباح
مثل الضوء يتغير لونه وبعد ذلك يكون
حرًا في مغادرة غرفته ليو ، سنقوم
بهذا الشيء الجديد الذي يسمى قواعد النوم
ليو ، لقد استمتع بصحبة أمي وأبي
في منتصف الليل
الجزء الآخر من وضع قواعد النوم
هو العودة الصامتة للنوم
حتى يصطدم بأمه ويعيده إلى
سريره ويذهب بعيدًا
ويمكن أن يحدث هذا النوع من الأشياء
عدة مرات
يحاول ابنك العودة إلى أسلوبه
القديم ثم يعطي  يصل لأنه لا يحصل على أي
تفاعل اجتماعي ، وإذا اتبع
هذه القواعد ، فسيحصل على بعض المكافأة ، ما هي
أفكارك حول الميلاتونين لطفلي
البالغ من العمر أربع سنوات ، لذا فإن البحث الجيد عن
الميلاتونين يظهر أنه غير فعال
للاستخدام في الأطفال أو الرضع.
لا نعرف مدى أمانه أو
ضرره ، فنحن لا نعرف أبدًا ، لذا لم
أقترح أبدًا بينادريل أو الميلاتونين لمساعدة
الأطفال على النوم ، لذلك
لا يريد لوك أن يذهب إلى الفراش
ولا يريد الجلوس و  قراءة الكتب
وقت القيلولة وإجراءات وقت
النوم مفيدة
حيث أن إشارات إلى أن النوم سيأتي
الآن ، ابني البالغ من العمر عامين ، لوك أصغر من
أن يفهم قواعد النوم ، لذا
اقترح الدكتور فايس بلوث أن يبدأ الأب
روتينًا لوقت النوم قبل نصف ساعة تقريبًا من النوم.
عادة نضعه في الفراش لذا
جربنا كل شيء في الأسبوع القادم ، سيكون
لدينا زجاجاتنا في الطابق السفلي ،
حسنًا ، ما هي قواعد النوم
في السرير
[موسيقى
] حسنًا ، لقد حان الليل
] حسنًا لقد كان  حوالي أسبوع
منذ
آخر مرة تحدثنا فيها ، فلنبدأ مع ليو ، طفلي
البالغ من العمر أربع سنوات ،
ما هي قواعد النوم الموجودة في السرير ،
حاول النوم ، يجب أن تضعها
في الصباح ، لم
يخرج من غرفته على الإطلاق وهو
نمت طوال
الليل ومثلما قلت إنك مدح  g
له وأنت تمدح سلوكه ،
فاستمر مع القليل من العلاج قريبًا
تأخير الرد وقل أن هذا مناسب
لك ولكننا سنحصل عليه بعد
العشاء مثل الحلوى وفي
المستقبل سننسى ذلك فقط و
لن يلاحظ حتى أنه لم يعد هناك المزيد من
الحلوى أو ملفات تعريف الارتباط بعد الحلوى
قال الدكتور فايسلوث إن تشجيع
سلوك ليو الجيد ساعد في تثبيط
عادة ابني في التسكع معنا بدلاً من
البقاء في السرير
الآن ، من ناحية أخرى ، كان لوك لا يزال لا
ينام طوال الليل  ولكن قبل النوم مباشرة ، كان
برايان يقرأ له وكان
أكثر هدوءًا حتى أنه كان يطفئ
الضوء بنفسه ، لذا سنستمر ونقدم
تقريرًا في غضون أسابيع قليلة
قبل الساعة 7 مساءً ، لقد حظيت بجمال
رائع.  سأقول روتين وقت النوم
ولأنه كان في مستوى أقل من
الإثارة العصبية ، فقد كان سلوكه أكثر هدوءًا في وقت مبكر من
المساء ،
وآمل ألا تشعر بالإحباط لأننا
لا نملك تحسنًا كبيرًا ،
لا أنا لست كذلك
لا أريد القيام بأشياء كثيرة
في  البدء في اتخاذ خطوات صغيرة في
بعض الأحيان هو الطريق للذهاب
[موسيقى]
لك